so what do you think holds people back
they know what they want to do but they
just can't keep the habit they do it
once and then they follow up the train
and then next you want to do it again
and they follow up the Train
how do you make that consistent well you
just keep you just keep working at it
and working it the best way of all is to
plan it in advance
instead of sitting down never start work
without a list and never start work
without prioritizing your list people
will sit down and they say well before I
make a list check a little email check a
little spam send something to my friends
see what's going on YouTube and so on
and so forth and then they look up and
it's 10 o'clock and they haven't got
anything of value so what you do is you
have to say you know well well you know
what what about whether they say but if
you started right it'll it'll it'll work
out right so started as week on your
most important tasks and do that until
it becomes a habit now here's an
interesting thing about checking email
is when you check email it triggers the
release of dopamine in your brain
dopamine is a drug but by the way
there's not all kinds of books and
articles and scientific studies on this
and dopamine is the same drug in cocaine
and what it does is it's triggered every
time you have a shiny object or
something new or different or
interesting or sparkly if a telephone
rings next to you you go ping your brain
releases endorphins and you can't hardly
wait to see what it is so you're talking
to somebody and you could be talking to
somebody about something very serious
and your telephone goes off ping your
whole mind books blank the middle of the
conversation stops you've grabbed for
your phone you pick it up you look at it
you check it out and everything else and
then you come back if you're working on
a task it takes an average of 17 minutes
to get back to the task and then there's
another distraction so another 17
minutes average adult is checking their
email between and and their phone
between 95 145 times a day that's very
easy which means they're like attention
deficit disorder dogs they're just going
to be running around back and forth the
whole day at the end of the day they're
exhausted I
USA Today and and Harvard approved that
you lose one IQ point for every hour
where you that you leave your email on
at the end of the day you've lost 10 IQ
points you actually become stupider
throughout the day dumber and here's a
ask this of my audience as I say have
you ever finished today well you don't
think you've accomplished anything
you've been on email responding to bings
and beeps and rings and so on all day
and at the end of the day you go home
and honey says what do you want for
dinner and you say I don't know I don't
care anything I just want to drink
because you're so exhausted you cannot
even decide sit there and basically like
you've just been you know punched in the
side of the head because your brain your
brain is dead and you lose 10 IQ points
you get stupider throughout the day
you've got to turn that darn thing off
if you want to remain sharp you know
what the habit you said way to do up the
habit and I'm going to give myself up my
reward and my reward will be to check my
email after I finished my first task so
so all of success in life is task
completion let me repeat that I just had
a long conversation with an entrepreneur
you almost fell off his chair I was
coaching him and he said he'd never
heard that before and then I spoke to
the methods group I was telling you in
Japan I told them the same thing and
they were just flabbergasted is the key
to success in life is task completion if
you don't complete tasks you have no
future and so if if task completion is
the key then what you do is you complete
more and more important tasks and if you
start every day by completing a the most
important task your brain actually
releases endorphins now endorphins is
another chemical and it's only released
when you do something that is life
enhancing and what that means is when
you do something that is good for you
that enhances your life that furthers
you it makes you happy it releases
energy it raises your self-esteem is
sort of safe if you if you want to be a
winner how do you be a winner where you
win and winning means you cross the
finish line so if you start and complete
a task you're actually winning and you
get a feeling of being
winner which gives you a suffusion of
energy and inspiration and it drives you
and motivates you to want to get that
feeling again so how do you get that
feeling again you start ugly to another
task so I've developed the habit and
people who are successful throughout the
habit of starting and completing tasks
so my wife comes in and says dinners in
five minutes
so I look at my list I say okay there's
a five-minute task and what are you
starting complete a five-minute task and
each time you complete a task you get a
burst of endorphin the bigger the task
the more endorphin the more endorphin
the more quickly you become addicted to
starting and completing important tasks
and every single successful person has a
reputation for starting and complete an
important test you want the job done
give it to him or her you want the
product served on time you'll have the
product completed you want the product
manufacture ship delivered give it to
him give it to her give it to that
company yes they always deliver that's
the best reputation you can have if you
want to get rich